okay so little history if you're younger
and you're watching this you may notice
that when you go to the video store or
hell if you still go to any video stores
you'll see a lot of Disney sequels like
Cinderella - or the Little Mermaid - or
Lion King - the reason for this is that
there was a time when hand-drawn
animation was dying I mean okay you
could argue it's not really around much
anymore especially cinematically but
Disney was losing it big time
most of their films were not making
money so they did a lot of direct-to-dvd
sequels and most of them were pretty bad
this is worth mentioning because one or
two actually made it to the big screen
and in this case it's return to
Neverland the sequel to one of Britain's
most beloved children's stories when it
came out it was panned the critics hated
it everybody said it's just another
directed DVD movie just thrown on the
big screen given a little bit more
budget it's a waste of time so that's
the movie I was waiting to see and
honestly I don't think that's what I got
okay it's not great but it was actually
a little better than what I was
expecting kinda sorta okay well it's
years later wendy has grown up and has a
family of her own but unfortunately it's
during wartime oh yeah we're going there
not only is Wendy's husband going off to
war but it also looks like that her
children one being the main character
Jane are about to get sent away because
of the bombings
Jane has forced herself to grow up
faster than most children because of the
obvious situation while Wendy still
tries to tell stories of Peter Pan and
imagination she just can't seem to get
into him anymore and understandably so
but that all changes when one night
Captain Hook returns kidnaps Jane and
takes her to Neverland as taking her for
Wendy but Peter man finds her and saves
her and thus she tries to figure out how
to get back home using her logic and not
really knowing how to use her
imagination so The Lost Boys had to
learn how to be more reasonable even
allowing a first Lost Girl and she has
to learn how to be playful and created
all while avoiding the evil grasp of the
Pirates the major criticisms that
everybody makes about this movie is that
it didn't need to exist and the right
this doesn't need to exist the first
Peter Pan is fine exactly how it is
both the book and the play hint that
there's
ventures that go on but it's not
something we always necessarily need to
know I guess from me though I grew up
with a show called Peter Pan and the
Pirates is a show not a lot of people
know about but it was damn good it
explored never landed explored the
characters and it treated it very very
seriously yeah did that need to exist no
but I would have missed out on all these
great adventures return to Neverland
kinda has a similar feel except in the
Disney universe it's still clearly the
Disney Peter Pan and the Disney Captain
Hook
in fact the voices they got to replace
them are amazing they sound just like
the original actors but that doesn't
mean anything if there isn't a good
story to go along with it and this story
yeah has a little bit of the lyre
revealed elements to it but it doesn't
focus on them that long and all the
other elements they kind of take from
the original book for example there's a
scene where Jane says she doesn't
believe in fairies I saw rolled my eyes
and said oh yeah well we all know what
this is because of the first movie wait
a minute they didn't do that in the
first movie we also have the
manipulation of hook with Wendy except
this time it has to be Jane but this was
a great scene too because it showed that
hook could be very clever he wasn't just
a dumb pirate who waved his sword around
he actually did have a little bit of a
mind and the struggle Jane goes through
is a very understandable struggle you
see the war they show you some of the
grittiness I mean okay not too far they
don't show dead bodies or anything but
they show it stuff she isn't just a
stick-in-the-mud you completely
understand why she has this mindset and
why it's hard for her to imagine things
heck why it's even hard for her to be
happy now with that said there
definitely are things you can complain
about
for example they have pop songs oh yeah
and they really don't fit this one song
that the Lost Boys sings that sounds
like a traditional Disney song but aside
from that all the songs are sung by pop
singers and their early 2000 pop singers
so they have this grachi but it's it's
supposed to sound tortured and it sounds
like it sounds like it's awful
it's distracting it's a slap in the face
every time there's supposed to be an
emotional moment I hate it when they do
this with Disney films especially ones
that take place such a long time ago and
in fantasy lands and you just hear this
incredibly dated mm song and ah it hurts
every time
you hear it also the voice actress for
Jane is kind of hitting miss sometimes
she really gets the lines right and
other times it sounds a little forced
but it's nothing too distracting there's
also some weird changes that I never
quite got like instead of a crocodile
they have this giant octopus or squid
something like that and now he's the
thing that chases Captain Hook it's
funny and it's still Annamayya well but
why didn't they just do the crocodile
they just say he's gone but why this
octopus thing does the exact same thing
I don't get why I need to switch it out
but for the most part what they do
switch out or keep in is actually kind
of welcome and besides that's not the
focus the focus is on Jane interacting
with the Lost Boys and trying to get
back her childhood which yeah sounds a
little familiar right I guess if you do
have to compare these two I would say
hook is the better movie but I don't
know for a sequel to Disney's Peter Pan
this is kind of exactly what I would
expect it has some really nice imagery
like when Oki is taking Jane to
Neverland this ship is flying through
London it looks amazing
there's a wonderful scene at the end
where young Peter Pan meets grown-up
Wendy and it plays out exactly how it
should play out it's not too emotional
but it's not too simple either that's
kind of how I think of the movie if
you're looking to find problems with it
you won't find any shortage you can
definitely find things that don't quite
work or maybe you've seen in other
movies and such but if you legitimately
want to see a sequel to Peter Pan and
you want to know what happens I think
this is a very delightful adventure I
was really surprised I was not expecting
to like this film I thought I was gonna
hate it like all the other critics did
but I actually kind of enjoyed it it's
not grand or epic but it's simple and
nice did it need to be made probably not
but since it does exist I think it's
fine
I think kids can watch it and get a lot
of laughs and adults can watch and enjoy
some of the more emotional moments it
felt like the people making it enjoyed
the subject matter and weren't forced
into doing it they appreciated the magic
and the imagination and the humor and
the artwork and they want to do
something very similar and it might
they succeeded I guess it's not a favor
for a lot of Disney fans but for me I
have no problem believing in fairies
with this one
you